If you wanna know how the tratt wife life typically ends,
we could just look at the Plathville,
if you don't know. What's that show?
Welcome to Plathville. This is basically ballerina farms,
but 25 years in the. In the future.
And what happens? Even though the woman
that whole agreement was. For 24 years they were married,
she was the one staying home with the kids.
She was the main caretaker,
the main parent, the default parent,
the one who they went to for everything while he was away at work.
When they divorced, what does he ask for?
He asks for full custody and child support and alimony.
So you enter a marriage where the arrangement is,
I'm gonna take care of the kids,
you're gonna work and provide for the family.
But then when that marriage ends now,
you're gonna turn around and wanna take the kids
and then ask me for money.
How the fuck? With what fucking job experience?
With what? With what? Anything?
All you've been doing is being barefoot and pregnant.
But that's how the Chad wife life ends.
Whether it's because he cheated on you and he left you,
or because you finally fucking wake up like most women do,
and realize, wow,
this is really sucks. This is really fucking miserable.
I love my kids, but this shit is not fun.
One way or another, the child wife life ends.
And what's gonna happen in the end?
All the. Everything that You poured into that family.
Look at how the husband is gonna treat you in the end.
So think about that before you wanna jump in.